p une conversation de malan de malraux
avec avec théodore et en temps j'entends
à oui mais eh bien vous raconter ce
qu'ils moi je les imagine
il parlait tous les deux en même temps
je sais pas 7 8 heures 10 heures de
suite
et s'il se croisaient ceci beaucoup
s'est passé en corrèze dans la maison du
facteur là où nous étions pendant la
guerre etc ils se parlaient ils
marchaient temps en temps je vais porter
un sandwich ou une banane quelque chose
il en avoir 5
pas du tout je ne sais pas comment il se
sait pour parler et a eu l'impression
d'assister à un match de ping pong
centre une se croisaient ils se
croisaient mais ce premier pas une
continuer par les talibans c'est la
loire côté délicieuse histoire comment
vous avez obligé malraux à faire une
course à vélo a perdu lamentablement à
vue l'homme avait agacé avec ça il était
une prétention avec son vélo c'est
possible mais comment est ce que vous
avez demandé à malraux au fond qui
prennent la relève de jean nohain oui
écrire des textes parfait et alors elle
m'a alors celle-là consterné elle était
très ennuyée il a essayé parce que
extrêmement gentil plein de bonne
volonté et j'ai tout de même extirper et
puis j'avais la funeste manie le facteur
m'avait acheté un piano un petit piano
droit et j'avais la fumée est humaniste
de l'huisserie n'est un air comme j'ai
l'habitude de faire pour que les poète
et parolier s'imprègne de ma musique je
il a sorti un verre deux verres de
beurre youtube et mis sous les arbres
l'été sous les arbres d'isère et ça
s'est terminé là et puis